moi si j'ai bien une qualité c'est que
je fais jamais de fautes d'orthographe
les gens qui écrivent bien ce qu'ils
font pas de fautes d'orthographe
les animaux se [ __ ] la honte en lisant
et en corrigeant ce que tu as écrit
légumes accents accents aigus les
humains soupe tuer mais taïg khris sauve
avec 5 p é heureusement qu'il existe des
claviers d'ordinateurs
chaque fois que je fais une faute sur la
même excuse non je pense que ça doit
juste être une faute de frappe
chose que tu peux pas faire quand tu
écris avec un stylo ah non moi je pense
que ça doit juste être une pote de
stylos pour on a le droit de se moquer
des gens qui font des fautes
voilà c'est bon enfant sauf sauf dans un
seul cas où c'est absolument interdit ou
là mais ya que des fautes que vous ne
sait pas écrire make way mais c'est
parce que je suis dyslexique
désolé c'est parce que je voulais dire
j'ai un profond respect pour toi et ta
famille je suis dyslexique
franchement j'ai tellement entendu que
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde dise
lexique variétés avec la dyslexie gens
présents que quand est dyslexique tu
peux le dire à toutes les sauces ça
passe tu arrives même pas soulevé
l'étagère
je suis dyslexique ok ce qui est celle
où c'est que le mot dyslexie et désigne
maladies liées à l'orthographe est lui
même le plus dur du monde à
orthographier pour les mecs ils ont
jamais pu écrire leur maladie une fois
bien guiche lexsi alors que le sida par
exemple c'est plus facile à ses fins et
pour moi je fais des fois des fautes
mais sur des mots un peu compliqué quand
même
par contre j'aimerais vraiment faire un
commentaire sur une faute qu'on voit
tout le temps c'est les mecs qui font
cette faute là ça va juste les mecs
apprenez le une fois
ça va cesser ses billes voilà c'est pour
toute la vie c'est bon après après c'est
fini
la plus besoin de la prendre c'est comme
le langage texto les des mecs qui
écrivent un langage texto
mais pas que dans les textos partout
dans la vie attendent imagine si tout le
monde faisait ça en quelques années ce
serait le bordel le président de la
république françois hollande à se serait
assis bas ce matin à son siège de
président et aurait affirmé à toute la
presse à tout va bien e
bon alors pour phrase qui sera peut-être
un jour culte peut-être pas ou peut-être
moyennement culte moi quand j'arrive
enfin à retenir l'orthographe d'un mot
c'est pas parce que je n'ai appris dans
un livre c'est toujours par des moyens
mnémotechniques un peu nul bienvenue ça
prend un peu oui
ah je vois que monsieur est un
littéraire ah non pas du tout c'est
parce que chez moi j'ai un paillasson
bienvenus d'accord juste comme ça
est-ce que tu aurais chez toi par hasard
un paillasson avec écrit en l'occurrence
non ok mais si je suis photographe alors
je suis pas dyslexiques
je suis quoi bah ça veut juste dire que
t'es con pas parfait vous êtes de plus
en plus nombreux sur ma page facebook
norman fait des vidéos
merci